it is day 5 92 since the beginning of  the end  there's no more government  for those survivors who are still with  us batten down the hatches make sure  your guns are clean and find a way to  protect yourselves  [Music]  you need to run don't stop until you get  to ben's go  you need to get to ben's  he was one of the best fbi agents i've  ever seen  he became a survivalist  why did you come here  we're gonna take the girl  we're gonna kill the rancher  you have 30 seconds to get off my  property  you can a give us the girl and let me  burn your ranch to the ground  or b  we will kill you  and take the girl anyway  don't let them take me  it's going to be a long night  i'm the one who decides who lives and  dies  me you come to my house you try to  kidnap this girl  and then you try to kill me  there are five of us there's one of him  i didn't ask you to come here  the girl is mine  she is my destiny  your destiny is gonna get you killed  you